Welcome back to Paragliding Atlas Podcast.
I'm your host Aninder Singh, and today a very special guest is
joining me. The reason why I say that is
because I have a very special announcement to make and that is
Paragliding Atlas would like to invite you on the most exotic
tours available in our sport to the most exotic places available
on this planet. And why I say we have a very
special guest because there is somebody who has been there,
done that and inspired some of us to do the same.
I'm talking about none other than Chris Garcia.
I hope I got your name correct my man Did I?
Yeah, yes, absolutely. All right, buddy, thank you so
much for joining me. You are the owner of Convergence
Para Lighting, which has got a super cool logo I believe.
Please tell us about you and how do you make so much awesomeness
in the world of para lighting? Awesome.
Thanks so much for having me and in there, yeah, I, I started
conversions paragliding in 2023. And the start really impetus for
this whole thing was that I'd always wanted to run a
paragliding tour in Cuba. My my father's from there.
I have close ties on the island still and, and years ago I was
developing sea kayak tours there, cycling tours, walking
tours. And so my natural background
coming from the adventure travel industry.
And once I fell into paragliding, all roads started
pointing me into this direction of having a travel company.
And I did not think it was going to grow to what it is today in a
short amount of time. But yeah, Cuba was really the
impetus for it, and that's what kind of kicked me off on
starting to go to unique places that are going to connect people
in a unique way to those destinations.
Cool. All right, Chris, when it comes
to exploring, you know, there's something about exploring new
places with your tribe and that is why I have been very
fascinated by, you know, sharing my passion with others because
vibing with your tribe is what life is all about, right?
Like, like you chase similar feelings and you chase
endorphins in a similar way and that kind of creates shared
value for everyone and you end up spreading smiles.
So how did the idea, you know, as you said from the onset, you
kind of were very curious about making tours in the industry,
which is not the usual go do thing for any paraglider pilot,
because a lot of them are more than happy just with the part of
flying. But I, I can relate it to relate
to this mindset a lot. And I, I want our listeners to
know the, the ideology that both of us have, I would say for
this. Yeah, I think that there's,
obviously I'm passionate about paragliding, but I'm also
passionate about travel and having the background that I did
in the adventure of travel industry for so long.
The the company that I worked with, they instilled a few
important things. And one of those was making sure
that people felt like they were connected to the resource where
they're going. And so often when we travel,
especially as pilots, we're really concerned about how far
we're flying, how long we're in the air.
And yes, that stuff is valid. It's important and we can learn,
especially on on tours and clinics with the right people.
But we're just passing through space, right?
We're just, we're flying through, we're not really
getting a sense of what it's like to be there.
And you, you take the 2 classic examples, I would say would be
like Via and then Columbia in the winter time.
You know, any time that I've gone there, when I go, I have a
great time. I fly a ton and I hang out with
my friends, but I hang out with my same friends that I see back
home in the States, right? And again, there's nothing wrong
with that. It's great to travel with
friends and share those experiences.
But sometimes I would leave was I even in Columbia?
And sure, you can have you get the local retrieve scene, you
land out. It's definitely an adventure.
But then we go back to our bubbles.
And sometimes I think that not only growing as a pilot in terms
of our skill set, but we should be trying to grow as a traveler
as human as well. And putting people in situations
where they have at least the opportunity to do that if they
want to. Yeah, I I feel this so relatable
because I think last year that is when I probably met you or
somebody from your from your company at Carrio launch in
Kenya where whosoever it was was very kind to give me my take off
video which I bragged about on Instagram later that day.
But it was like just going to Kenya itself was such a cool
experience. And I mean, just to let the
listeners know, I was not with Convergence.
I was with a whole different tour run by Sky Nomad, which is
again, one of those, you know, guys who who runs a very cool
exploration company. And it was nice not just flying
for the sake of flying and flying for the sake of
exploration where you are able to see the world from above.
And then once you're done that you're still curious to go out
and explore it on the ground because a lot of times, you
know, it's like paragliding is maybe kind of a tunnel vision
thing that you get so absorbed in the epic stimuli that you're
a part of. I'm not going to lie.
Like it's like such a huge blessing that as humans, you get
to see a bird's eye view and do that for hours and days or like
have goals and, you know, things to to kind of accomplish.
But a lot of times we do forget that how amazing it is to be a
man or like a mankind that you can walk and still explore the
planet that way. And intertwining both of these
deliverables and exploring remote places is like, it just
blows my mind. And it's like, how much more fun
can life do that when you add the fun factor of doing with
people who are chasing the same endorphins as I said earlier.
Yeah, absolutely. I think it's, but again, it's
these types of tours, they're not for everyone.
Some pilots are more they're focused on the numbers side of
thing, which is totally fine. It's a noble pursuit as well,
but some folks when they go on a flying vacation, it's also a
vacation. It's not supposed to be this
kind of pressure cooker of having to perform.
And so by going to these unique places, it takes a little bit
less of the pressure off flying of maybe you have bad weather,
maybe the conditions are marginal or you don't have the
skill set for it. And there's so many other things
to do on the ground that it's, oh, yeah, you know what?
Today it's not a big deal. I'm not going to fly.
I'm going to go to Africa's first locally owned elephant
orphanage and see how they bring elephants up from babies who
have been abandoned and then reintroduce them into the wild.
So there's tons of stuff to do out there other than just fly.
Yeah, there's numbers game is pretty fun, but like just adding
more pluses to it or more deliverables.
But I'm curious what kind of pilots are usually the target
audience for this? And of course, I'm asking for
myself, but for the listeners who are like curious if this is
these kind of tours are for them, Like how do their flying
type or you can say flying trajectory looks like in their
lives that they know that they can have fun on these kind of
tours? Yeah, I think we take the pilots
of wide variety skill sets. I've had folks come who've just
gotten their beginner license or their P2 known in the US and
I've taken pilots who have thousands of hours.
One of the things that we really try to focus on is that we have
a small guide to guest ratio. And so we'll run with three to
one or sometimes 2:00 to 1:00. And we run small group sizes as
well. Some of our some of our bigger
tours, Kenya, Bhutan, Socotra will limit those to maybe four
people, sometimes 6 at most depending.
But then something in like Cuba, for example, we might have as
many as 9, but we always have enough staff on hand that we can
break the groups up as needed. So no one ever feels like
they're holding anyone back and no one ever feel they're being
held back. And again, it's a paragliding
company. We want to fly, we're here to
fly. And if the day presents itself
that we can actually go out there and send it.
We do, but sometimes we don't and we keep it easy, we can work
on. Again, it depends on the
destination and what we can do. Like the classic example of one
that's been more XC and skills focused over the last few years
is our Macedonia tour. So I partnered up when I first
started conversions with Martin Jovanowski.
He's the local legend there and Khrychevo and Martin's been just
such a great addition to the team.
And we really dive in on, you know, whether it's route
planning or route choices throughout the day over there in
Khrychevo or working on more of the technical side of things in
terms of thermaling. And we've had pilots who are
brand new P twos show up on that trip and pilots who have
thousands of hours again, who are learning in the same format
side by side from another. Yeah man, flying is is fun, no
matter at what hour limit it comes in in different like when
it comes to learning is what is what I meant to say.
But yeah, Cruciva is Mecca of racing is one way to put it.
But just exploring the nitiquities of flying a
paraglider because of the possibilities that it offers
you. Flatland, mountains, gusts,
normal conditions, everything the place throws quite a fun mix
at you every time you take this kind of.
Absolutely. And that's been Christian has
been a popular destination for quite a while now, especially in
the European and there's been plenty of operators over there
for a while. But on the American side of
things, there really wasn't anybody going there to run
proper tours. And so that's why I started off
of Macedonia. And what was that?
July of 2023 was the first tour that I ran.
And the reason I picked that was 1.
I had a little bit of a relationship with Martin Reddy
and knew the insurance and outs there from having raced there
from a few years ago, and I had to find a way to be able to fund
my reconnaissance trip to go to Cuba and set the whole thing up
there. So that's what kind of ended up
snowballing from Macedonia and then to Morocco and then right
into Cuba. It's all about getting the
momentum, then everything else just figures itself out.
So I'm hoping to jump on a similar bandwagon when I start
my journey in this, which is fairly soon.
Any anytime now when I fix my you can send numbers in the bank
account to to get it going because that is 1 commonality
that anybody who flies can relate to.
Yes, it's not easy to make it in the sport.
There are those of us who do. And yeah, it's, it's a grind
like anything, right? It's, I think it's a very fun
job that we have, but it's still a job at the end of the day and
it takes time and effort. You know how I look at it is
that of course you can find 100 reasons to whine about it, but
it's buddy. It's either this or sitting
behind a 15 inch screen for a nine to five or someone else
who's just paying you to give up your time.
So you have two options. Which one do you want to whine
about? OK, I'll happily take the flying
part. 100%. Yeah.
Well, Chris, three years, man, that's insane With the amount of
offerings that you have. Is there like some things that
you have done that you notice or?
OK, I can say that this could be a bit of like curiosity of mine
because I want to be a part of the tribe and grow the whole
thing as well. Of course there are one things
running professionally, doing everything by the book and
making sure you're not slacking off, but just being able to grow
in a safe manner, which is the paramount in any sort of flying
activity and still keep pushing the bar when it comes to
exploration. Some sort of mantra.
What is your go to thing that that allows you to scale on on
that level? Yeah, I think, you know, first,
no, no tour is really complete without the heartbeat of it.
And the heartbeat of it is our local staff in in places where
there are local pilots, they take Cuba or even using Martin
and Macedonia, for example, connecting with them, making
sure that we have them on board and that they feel that they're
a part of the whole thing. Because when the weather gets
tricky or there's no flying to be had or there's an incident,
the locals are going to know best how to deal with those
situations. And again, like this, every
company runs things a little bit differently And sometimes
people, they go to a place so often that they just get it
dialed. And I go here every year and I
feel like I'm the local now. And sure there's you're using
local hotels, retrieved drivers and whatnot, but I really try to
focus on including the local pilot community, even if they're
maybe not up to par in terms of the skill set of the other
guides or staff on the trip. They learn from it too, and
pilots really like getting to know our pilots that come on the
tours. They want to know what it's like
to be a pilot in whatever destination that we're in.
So I think that's that's really important.
There aren't any local pilots flying there.
We're making sure that we have proper local contacts on the
ground for our local operators that are handling everything.
And there I'll get my hands involved a little bit more in
depth with things to shape it and structure it how I think it
should be. And yeah, apart from the local
side of things, I think that a, a mantra and so to speak is.
And what I tell people when we go to somewhere we've never
taken off before, like our entire tour in Mongolia is you
got to have a beginner mindset behind it, right?
As guides and pilots who have travelled the world and
experienced a variety of different conditions and sites,
we're doing the best we can with what we're seeing with our eyes,
what we're experiencing with weather in the in the moment and
based what we see on the forecast.
And, but we're still taking it with a grain of salt.
That's yeah, we're just happy to be here, you guys.
And so when you're on a in a remote location, that's not the
time for anybody to push it, whether that's me as a pilot or
me as a guide and also someone else that's coming on the tour.
And so I like to tell folks that we have, we have our margins
that we fly with daily basis. And when you go somewhere
completely new, even if you're under the wing of a tour, you
know, especially in places where emergency retrieval or access is
not going to be quick, you got to make them a little bit bigger
and take a step back that way. And again, that's where coming
into the point of going to unique places and giving people
the option to either not fly or take a shorter flight because
there's really cool things to do just makes it easy.
There was so many points that I wanted to jump on, but before I
forget, I just want to let people know that.
Head over to convergenceparaglighting.com.
Of course, we're going to put the link in the show notes and
then just go to their missions and values.
That itself tells you what Chris just explained in the past few
minutes about how cool it is and giving back I think is a lot
more satisfying than we think. And the essence of including the
locals. I completely vibe resonate with
it because I think there's something special about your
home ground because there is a comfort zone that no other place
will give you. We know this from big teams
which play like the big leagues for conventional sports but in
para lining as well. Like I started my journey in
beer billing in the Himalayas and even today the art of
exploring those giants is bigger comfort than I would say
exploring the Alps where I have flown for much longer than I
have in my home ground. But just the you can call it
psychological, you can call it like placebo, whatever it is.
But there is something about home ground which local pilots
will thrive at much better than than the than the foreigners.
So natives versus foreigners at the angles coming to my mind.
But yeah, I kind of want to come to your home ground because
Cuba, man, as an American, the Cuba country itself, and I know
you have a whole section listed on your website about travelling
to Cuba as AUS citizen. I don't know.
Let's dive right in. Yeah, please.
Do. You know, it's funny because I
have, so I have a tour that actually one of my guys is
coming by my house this afternoon to pick up stuff to
take. They fly out tomorrow and I have
a tour starting on Sunday in Cuba.
And so I just got back five days ago, I believe from our first
week there and have another one going out here.
I'm going to be at home. I'm on daddy duty while my wife
is on a certification. She's been putting up with me
going on these trips for a number of years now, so it's
nice to see her. That sounds fun.
Yeah. There's a lot of exotic places.
I can't wait to talk about. Mongolia, Socotra, goddamn, how
cool is that? There are only planned
expeditions by brands and there's somebody's like, hey,
give me a chance and I'll make you fly sock coats, right, man.
So like we'll talk about like all of these, but quickly, Cuba,
what is it all about? How is it?
Because the only reference that I have of that country is from
the colorful, you know, vintage cars and these buildings and
Instagram photos and stuff. I don't know anything more about
that place. So for me, being a Cuban
American, I was born in Chicago, but my father immigrated in the
70s with his whole family. Cuba was a super special place
for me and it is one of the most unique places in the world.
It's full of juxtapositions and it just contradicts itself
constantly. And it's been in the news.
What's that? Well, just like a conflicting
ideas, it shows you one thing here and then the next where you
look, you're like, wait, how can those two exist side by side?
And that's the beauty of Cuba. It's that until you go there,
you don't. And even then, I've been going
there for a decade and I still come back with more questions
than I have answers for each. It's been in the news recently.
Lately, obviously everything that's been going on with after
Venezuela and talk of regime change and whatnot, I don't.
Want to say after everything that's been going on with the
orange man and then everybody will get the right that is 1.
But Cuba is, they're very resilient and it's a beautiful
island and the people are extremely kind and they're very
friendly. Most people, when they think of
Cuba, they think of the old cars, they think of Havana.
It's just a quick 40 minute flight from Miami.
And I spent a lot of time in that part of the country and a
decade ago when I was developing different types of tours.
But when I wanted to set up the the paragliding tour in Cuba,
that made the most sense to go down to the southeastern end of
the country in Santiago de Cuba. Santiago, located in a nice
little Bay right there. We stay right downtown and our
main takeoff is 30 minutes from our hotel.
It's one of the only drive up sites in Cuba that you can
actually go and thermal flying cross country from pretty much
everything else you have to hike up to.
That's why we picked it there. And just to the West of town is
the Sierra Maestra, which is very large mountain range and
believe it or not there's 2000 meter peaks there which is hard
to meet. Ground level or sea?
Like on ground or from sea? From sea, yeah.
Yeah, OK. That's how much is the altitude
from ground from like how high. Yeah, it's it's 2000 meters
above the ground. Oh damn bro.
Yeah, you're just right on the ocean, just the mountains go
straight up. It's pretty.
Dude I want to see some photos from there.
Damn that sounds super nice. Yes, it's beautiful.
We had actually had a really nice flight on the South Coast
that hadn't been done before in this last trip.
It's it's this big S facing range that runs east West and
it's very similar to what I fly here at home in in Santa
Barbara. We have a similar set up close
to the coast and so it it made sense in a lot of ways.
And I was going around on X contest.
It's usually where I start. Most of my research is so if I
want to go somewhere, let's see what's been done and who's the
pilot who's flying the most there.
And that's how I reached out to a few different folks in Cuba
and ended up getting in touch with the Huello Libre club from
Santiago. And they're the heartbeat of our
entire trip. We have 4 of their pilots who
work for me. Pablo, he's our main fixer.
He does all of our logistics in terms of getting everybody on
the right car, making sure everyone's retrieved.
And then we have 3 local pilots that fly with us.
Frank, Ernesto, Sergio, those guys are super nice.
They're really sweet. And while I'm trying to convince
them to take English lessons and I've said I've paid for it, a
big part of their main function is not only supporting the main
paragliding guides that come down in terms of decision making
on the weather, but it's also if someone lands in a really weird
spot, their main function is they go down, they land with
them, and they make sure that they get out in a timely manner.
It's timely, it's Cuba things, it's island time.
Things can happen a little bit slower than you want, but we get
to you eventually. I mean, that itself is the kind
of own experience when you're like especially I feel like, I
mean, like I can generalize this in developed economies or
Western countries where life is super damn fast that, you know,
it just blazes by. And then you go to these island
nations especially, where like people are still having the same
24 hours in the day, but spending it in a lot more
indulgence. Indulgence maybe is the right
word. They're just existing.
And time is, yeah, like it's, it's like the the planet
revolves a lot more slower in those in those places.
But yeah, for travel is an American citizen coming to Cuba.
It's relatively straightforward. We have a license that's from
the OR the Office of Foreign Assets and Control that allows
us to travel under one of their thirteen different categories
for the Cuba, it being support for the Cuban people.
And really what that means is it's not about it's not about
donations, it's about dialogue so much.
And so the way that the US government has put it is that if
you're going to Cuba and you're interacting with people who, you
know, everyday people on the island, they think that
therefore they'll adopt our, you know, belief system in terms of
capitalism and that it's better. And that eventually they'll use
that energy to overthrow the regime, which it's, that's,
it's, it's funny that they do that, but that's what allows us
in the government's eyes, for us to go travel down there to Cuba.
I've always just gone on a family visa.
I still do that every time I go. It's a much more straightforward
process than people think. Again, we set it up, walk you
through the entire process until you're there in the country to
make sure you're good to go. Does Cuba has oil or they just
want to overthrow it for the fun of it?
Yeah, you read the reports. There hasn't been oil that's I
think been shipped to the island and there's some people are
saying three months. The traffic's always been just
there, non existent on the island.
I'd say as far as on the road, it's probably down about 60%
from what our driver had told me from this last week.
We have enough gas allotted for us.
We've piled back our operation a little bit.
We're limiting ourselves to a box triangle area so to speak.
And again, it's we can get some fantastic flying in there.
You can. Fly.
No, what I meant was like, is it a natural resource heavy country
that was like. You're shifting away?
No, definitely not. I'd say it's, I think it's
biggest export is nickel from a mine that's up in, up in.
Yeah. So it has something if not oil.
So that makes. Sense, yeah, I think a good.
Regime overthrow thing is on the cards always.
No, but let's talk about flying man.
How does flying look like? Is it possible to sign 150K?
Of course, 2000, that's like huge.
No, 100%. Last year from Porto Bonato,
which is our local launch that we use out at Santiago, we had a
group fly 120 kilometers. Unfortunately, we had to land
early that day. We accidentally broke a
presidential TFR that we didn't know about and got the word we
have to land. There's no big deal.
It's a little stressful there for a a bit, but again.
How did you work? With the white people on the
island. So what's that?
How did you get the word? What?
How did somebody notice? My main fixer there, Pablo, he's
the president of the Air Sports association for that entire
region in Cuba. So he got a phone call and then
radioed through SO. They had eyes on you.
Yes, they do. And that's The thing is I we
don't try to ever go there and pull a fast one on these guys
because they definitely pay attention and it's all just
about open dialogue and working with them.
And a couple phone calls later, everything was fine.
But I know that the crew is bummed because we're 120
kilometers in, there's three hours left of daylight and
everybody's at cloud based 2000 meters above the island.
Another day my family, like last thing you want to be is like
have some projectiles coming at you from the ground.
Definitely not there anyways. But yeah, no, there's a lot of
potential there. I think the, let's say three
years ago, Cuban Canadian guy, he set the national record of
230 K So there's definitely potential for some distance
there. You got it's got to be the right
day and the right convergence line up.
But yeah, you can have some seriously big flights.
Yeah, no wonder I I get the essence behind your name.
Convergence, Fire lighting. Tell me about Socotra, man, what
is this place? What is it called?
Yeah, Macedonia, a lot of other places.
Super nice. But holy shit, Socotra, which is
the only exposure I think any flyer has, is from the Nova
movies that they made a couple of times.
And other than that, it's in the news for every kind of a bit of
a trouble, but yeah. What is this little paradise all
about? And how does life look like in
the air over there? So Sokotra, it's known as the
Galapagos of the Indian Ocean. There's over 500 different
endemic species of flora and fauna there, and it's quite the
place. And the flying there is
absolutely amazing. And yeah, as most of us, all we
know about Sokotra is from the Nova videos.
I believe it's like 2010 maybe. And then Theo did one a little
bit more recently, and that kind of sparked a lot of people's
interests. Again, this one's probably one
of the more complicated places that I've run, even more so than
Cuba. Sure.
It was brought up to me by Sean Mosley.
So Sean, he's a Kenya pilot and he approached me sometime after
our Kenya trip. This is 2025, and was like, hey,
I have a friend who runs logistics on the island.
I think it would be really cool to do a tour there.
Do you think you can pull it together?
And I started researching. I was like, wow, like this looks
absolutely incredible. Wasn't even on my radar.
And so I reached out to some of my regular guests that come on
my tour and I was like, hey, this is a potential we have to
act quickly because this logistically with flights,
permits, everything else, it has to be done way in advance.
So I hit up some folks, I said, hey, this is what we're going to
do. Are you in?
And they said 100% yes. So we got enough pilots signed
up early on and we were able to make it happen.
This was, I think Sean called me end of April with this idea.
And we had the deposits in by middle of May ready to go and
just took advantage from it from there.
Yeah, it was pretty great. And again, it's all about
knowing the right people to get you in and to get you set up for
success there. And Sean, he's my main Kenya
guide, one of the guys that I use most when I'm in Africa.
And he was also guiding with me there in Socotra.
Sean and our local operator, they went in the week before and
they went and just scouted a few different places, options based
on wind direction, whether it was northeast, northwest.
He went and found a few different launch sites and then
we just planned the tour out from there and we were on the
island for seven days and we flew six of those seven.
So it was pretty good and consistent I would say too.
The first question that I want to ask you is that in reality,
is it looking as spectacular as it does in the video or is it
just color grading doing it's magic on the screen?
No, it looks just as spectacular in real life.
Absolutely. Yeah, it is.
I would say too, that, you know, on on some of those shots that
you see in the videos, we had quite a bit of overcast days
just in terms of cloud layer that were coming in.
Still very much flyable. There's more to be had in terms
of color there. But yeah, it's just such a wild
and magical place. And not only the coastline there
and the dunes and that stark contrast, but also going up deep
into the mountains and the Dragon's blood trees as well.
It's breathtaking. Yeah, those trees, man, they
look out of the place. Like honestly, they're out of
the world. That's what I wanted to say very
much. There's something about Africa
that is quite fascinating, the way the way flora and fauna
thrives and that kind of you can say belt of the planet, the
ecosystem, even though it's so arid, dry and like it's got it's
own harsh environments, but like quite fascinating.
Africa has been drawn more and more to that continent over the
last few years and that's where a lot of future trips are going
to be taking place that we're starting to get into.
I'm very curious about Madagascar, man.
Imagine flying over ball and stuff.
I think there was somebody because Reunion.
There are some tours that go, especially Frenchies.
But I did see a video super old, like maybe a decade old or
something. Somebody vinching in Madagascar
with a tour or something? Yeah, there's been a few people
who've flown Madagascar. That one's definitely on the
list. Future projects right now in
terms of Africa this December, hopefully going to South Africa.
And then Angola and Algeria are both on the list for future
projects right now. Damn, I wish maybe I had their
airspace open as well. I think somebody like I, I read
it somewhere that they, I don't know what reason, but they don't
allow. But that looks quite spectacular
too with the red side. Yeah, and maybe and maybe it
looks great as well. I think that you can probably
get there. But that's like the thing about
making sure that you're talking with the locals when you're
going to these places because that's a classic one where I
think from my understanding, things got shut down there
because people were flying under the radar or sites they
shouldn't have been. And that's where the
government's just no, we're no more like Bhutan is one of those
two where there were tours running there 20 years ago or
so. And the government all but shut
it down. And now there's quite a lengthy
permit process for it to happen, which in a lot of ways good
because it's what kind of protects free flight in that
area. You don't want people just
coming in and ruining it without following local rules and
regulations, as silly as they might seem for some of us who
are coming from more developed parts of the world.
We are bound to respect the regulations and pay a huge
amount in the developed countries.
Like it's just about a mindset shift that when we reach a place
where you can say lawlessness, which is not really the correct
word, it is the normal like we expect.
Holy shit this should be easier than what it seems like.
It's just like we got to respect local rules and customs, however
we might feel about them inside. But at the end of the day, if
I'm working closely with the government, like in Bhutan, for
example, they tell me to jump. I'm like, oh, hi, what do you
guys want? I'll, because I'll make it
happen. And that's, that goes a long way
in, in terms of disrespect and then creating more dialogue to
maybe ease the process down the road.
So quotra, man, before I move on to the other one, how does
flying look? Is it mostly soaring or is there
some circling here and there? What is the average flight time?
What are the wind conditions just out of curiosity?
Yeah, I think there it's generally stronger wind.
We were there at the end of October and it was a little bit
lighter. It's on the monsoonal switch
from southwest to northeast. And I'd say flying, it's a
little bit of everything. It's it's, it's rich soaring
with thermals mixed in. There is some potential for some
really nice flying in the mountains on the right day, but
it's got to be the right day with light winds.
If you have a strong northeasterly flow, you don't
want to be high up in there. My guy Sean, he the week before,
he got just an absolutely epic flight next to some of these
cool Spires just thermalling around, had a beautiful, I think
30 kilometer cross country flight over to the beach.
And in terms of flight time, again, it depends.
I think we were in the air, we polluted usually twice a day.
We would fly in the mornings from for 2-3 hours or so, then
we'd come relax back at camp in the middle of the day, go
swimming, snorkeling, and a lot of that was just because we
wanted to take a break and go enjoy the island.
And then we'd go back out in the evening again and go fly.
If it were any stronger, probably wins during the middle
of the day, we might have to shut it down.
But again, each day is different.
I think one of the biggest things when it comes to flying
in Socotra is that you have to, you can fly some cross country,
but you have to be careful where you're flying over.
Part of working with the right people that we do is they go
around to each village and they talk with the elders and they're
like, hey, this is what we're going to be doing.
This is how many people we have. They're going to be flying and
they go and get permission to do so beforehand.
Whereas if you just start going around flying wherever you want
and it's very conservative Islam there and in their enclaves and
where they're living, it's a space where people can relax a
little bit, especially the women.
They don't have to be fully covered up necessarily depending
on the family. And if they see someone flying
overhead or even nearby, it can raise alarms and it can feel
uncomfortable. And that's the last thing that
we want to do. So but one thing that's really
important for anybody going to the island to to know about is
that you can't just go up and send it wherever you want.
There's times that and conditions that we get that
opportunity and we will go exceed.
But it again, depends on the day.
But the last thing we want to do is upset anybody on the island.
Keep everyone happy. What what what does life on
ground look like? Obviously when you're walking
around and resting, or let's say better than local clothes like
you, you stand out. Having huge backpacks doesn't
help. So what is there like?
How does attention from the natives look like in in that
side of the world? And how's the safety aspect of
it? Oh, I think the safety aspect,
it's extremely safe. They're generally very curious,
especially with the gliders. That's something that they're
not used to seeing very often at all.
And one of the beautiful parts about working with the right
people is that we're able to go to parts of the island that
other tourists aren't necessarily going to.
A lot of tourism on Socotra, for better or worse, is like
influencer tourism where they're going to get the shop on the
dune or you're going to take the photo at the beautiful Bay with
the colorful water. And you these, the people that
go with the normal operators, they're going, they're all
congregated in the same spots. And so we get out of that area,
especially when we go up into the Dragon's blood forests and
up on the Dixon Plateau, where we're not seeing really hardly
any tourists at all. And the locals that are there,
they're generally curious and then they're friendly too.
And I think in terms of safety, obviously Yemen's another one of
those countries. It's been in the news a lot up
until recently. Socotra had a big influence from
the Emiratis. And so they were there helping
with just medical infrastructure, solar,
everything, just basic needs being met.
And that helped with a big stability, a big portion of the
stability on the island. There was not really unrest that
you might hear about in the mainland as of a few months ago,
that Socotra is now under Saudi influence, which I think from
what I'm being told in some ways is going to be a good thing
because they're restricting the amount of people who can come
onto the island now. Whereas the Emiratis were
allowing. There's two flights a week
coming in from Abu Dhabi and now that's being back, restricted
back to one flight a week. The island's really small and it
can only support a certain amount of people, especially
because there's only really one or two hotels, I think in
Hadibo, which is the capital there.
Everything else is camp based. So if you're coming to the
island for tourism, you have to have a camp set up and you're
limited on your luggage intake too, so you can't just come in
with your own gear. You have to go with a company
who already has stuff on the island and permits and
sustainability reasons as well. Sounds like such a adventure,
man, which needs like it's always risk versus reward.
So here it's effort versus reward that you got to put in
the effort to get the gem in the air.
But yeah, do you have any experiences?
What's your craziest adventure on any of these trips that you
have been taking to the to such remote locations?
Yeah, no, that's a tough one because a lot of these places,
it's everything has its own, you know, you unique thing.
I'd say culture was just absolutely incredible.
Yeah. I think there's never been like
any like, sketchy or dangerous situations.
I see like the biggest drama we've had was probably that
flight in Cuba last year that we all had to come down and land
and then basically had to go apologize to the government for
making that happen. But everything else, again, it's
we try to run things in a way, we streamline logistics that
when there's so there's no drama, it's a drama free type
tour and people are feeling like they're getting that adventure.
I think one of my God, all of them are my favourites, all
these tours. But you were talking about
Mongolia earlier. That one's just unique in that
as soon as you're outside the city, it's public land
everywhere. It's a nomadic lifestyle there.
People have spring, summer, fall and winter camps, and everybody
will respect each other's camp as they tend to move around.
But it's all public lands. We're on a mobile camp set up as
well, embracing that nomadic lifestyle.
So essentially just drive around until we figure out like, all
right, we have an idea of where we're going, but this setup
looks nice. We'll set up camp here and then
from there we decide where we're going to go fly based on
weather, the aspect of the hill where the sun's going to be
hitting it in the morning, and then we'll drive up as far as we
can and get out of the Land Cruisers and we'll start walking
from there. Land Cruisers in Mongolia, holy
shit doesn't get any better than that.
I know, right? Yeah, but I get it, like you
need 4 by fours for that. But Mongolia, that that's a
flattish country. Of course it might have some
hills. Like I've only seen photos of
like vast grasslands and windy areas like.
It's very mountainous, though I will say it's nickname is known
as the Land of the Eternal Blue Sky, which high pressure pretty
stable. But outside of that, those
months where it's just the land of the eternal blue sky in, in
July and August in particular, you can have some pretty nice
flying. You can get some instability in
there and sometimes it's a little bit too much instability.
When we were there this last August in 2025, we had some
pretty big weather that was coming through.
But again, we were able to fly most days.
A lot of it was early in the morning.
I can fly making sure we're getting down even as early as
10:00 sometimes because it can come through pretty quickly and
especially gust fronts there things, it travels very quickly.
It's like flying in the Intermountain West in the US You
have to take any development very seriously there.
But we were able to find some really magical moments and have
some nice flying. I'm.
Just curious, how does the like, how accurate is the forecasting?
Because of course we have meteor blue, we have sky site and all
those windy and stuff like those things which function super well
based on the community feedback on hotspots where the
paragliding is common thing. But like in remote locations we
we tend to apply similar tools, but how close do we get on
figuring out the right conditions?
It depends on where you're at. I try not to go 2IN depth in a
place like Mongolia. We'll look at Windy.
I think the ECMWF will pop up there.
I'll take a quick glance at surface.
I'll go up through altitude. I'll try to look at a bigger
picture too and just put the isobars on the map and see
what's going on in the area. But there's no better tool out
there than your own eyes and seeing what's going on.
And so just taking from years of flying in other places that
experience and also taking the account, the forecast, we go
from there. But again, sometimes things
happen just really quickly and you've gotten your intuition
just as you know what, now it's time for us to get on the ground
because the forecast might have said one thing, but obviously
it's changing. I think that's anywhere, and in
reality, we're not going to just completely redesign the tour,
pick up camp and move it because of the weather.
You can do that in some places like the Alps, right?
If you're on a tour there, it's OK.
Like we're going to jump over to this valley.
The weather looks much better there for the foreseeable
future, and that can make sense. But on some of these other
tours, we try to put people in the right place at the right
time of year. But again, OK, we can't go fly
in Mongolia today. We're going to go visit a Kazakh
family who uses a golden eagle to hunt with instead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what excites me about
these places now like in in Kenya as well, which has been
my, you can say remote ish exploration from the usual
sites. It's every single landing is not
the end of a adventure. Sure, it's an end of a flight,
but totally shed the amount of experiences could be good or
bad, like whatever. I'm not going to label it any
which ways because any experience can go either way.
But yeah, you're still going to stay excited until you reach
back to your hotel because the, the the stimuli is going to be
so interesting from what you're used to that it, it keeps you on
your toes and mostly in a good way, because people are warm
when they see humans from the sky coming down and walking
around like normal people. Absolutely.
Yeah, Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
One thing that I was wondering is you had shopper tours to go
to take Austin, Kenya. Let that sink in.
People like to anybody who's listening to this right now, who
has gone this far, who has, who has stuck with us for this far,
Chris has managed to take a whole different transport to
take offs. We are used to hiking, which is
like the most common way to put your aircraft on your back and
hike up. We are used to driving but Chris
flies to his take off and then flies in a different.
Yeah. That's our Kenya tour in the
north that we do, yeah. Yeah, like N is exciting enough
because there's not a lot of tourism developed there.
So what is? What is Chopper like?
How to tell me a little bit about it?
Kenya tour in the north was designed by Sean Mosley.
Sean owns a safari company there in Africa and he's been a pilot
for about a decade now and he runs these high end tours there.
And one of the things that they do, the lodges, they take a
helicopter up and they go have a nice happy hour, a sundowner as
they call it in Kenya. And Sean would be standing up
there with his guests. He's like, wow, he could totally
fly a paraglider off the spot at the adventurer and explorer he
is. He was just like, wow, I think
that this would work to go and fly, but the only way to reach
that is is by helicopter or just a massive, massive hike through
dense forest, leopard, Buffalo and elephant, which unless
you're a local Samburu, you might not be too keen on on
walking up there yourself. So when I got connected with
Sean a few years ago, you know, I've tried to put together this
tour in Kenya and he says, how do you feel about helicopters?
I'm like, what do you mean helicopters?
And I was like, all right, mate, I'll try to sell it.
I don't know. This is it's so new and we made
it happen and we just ran that tour again this past January.
Fantastic. And so it does a couple things.
It allows us to get the access up there and it also provides
safety when it's, you know, 45° down on the floor in northern
Kenya, you land out in the middle of nowhere.
You have the confidence that you're going to get picked up
quickly because there's hardly any roads at all.
A lot of it's only accessible if you take a Bush flight or if you
have a chopper to get around. And I think, you know, I have to
credit Nikki from Sky Nomads, who you went with last year.
He's done a lot of flying up there in the north of Kenya and
Ethiopia and all that. And I know he had his thoughts
on the chopper last year and. Yeah, he doesn't like.
Yeah. He came around to it this year
though, for sure, I think. And one of the things that that
Sean did a really good job of, of explaining to people that I
tried to do is that you're not just up there ripping around
burning jet pool for the hell of it.
A lot of the money that we're spending, especially on that
tour in particular, is going back to the people who live
there, the Samburu people in northern Kenya, the lodges that
we stay at or it's land that's leased from them.
We're getting permission to go to these spots and making sure
that we're talking with the local community so they know
what's going on. I really want to bring in this
because this has been on my mind for quite a few days and it's
you can say it's personal, but like we can all I saw this meme,
I don't know if it was on YouTube shots or Instagram reads
or something. It said that I am drinking from
soggy paper straws to save the planet.
And then there's a next visual of this like huge oil field and
it says world leaders are blowing up oil fields for fun.
It's OK man. You can talk about my carbon
footprint when I'm having fun, but what about the real cost of
existing on the planet for covering up your stupidity when
it comes to being critical about the resource usage?
Feel free to have your opinion, but be aware at the same time as
well. And bottom line is, if your
retrieve looks as cool as a frickin chopper, I'm signing up
for everybody. Take my money and let me be a
part of the drive. Again, we take cars.
We take cars up to take off. We drive a lot.
We're not just hiking every single time, you know?
Again, don't knock it until you try it.
Yeah, yeah. But do you guys have the chopper
for the whole day or is it like is that?
So we, we contract it for a number of hours usually like
that, it depends, but we have it for roughly 6 days total.
So we go up and we actually do a family camp up on one of the
take offs there in the north and that's how we start things.
So we'll fly the bed rolls up there, the kitchen, everything
will stay out under the stars. Wake up and go for a nice
sunrise flight. It's been fun.
We've had a few sites that shown his ID that have worked over the
last few years. And then OK, like it's too windy
up high, we need to find something a little lower.
We have the ability to go fly around and find a nice Ridge
that's set up into the wind where we can actually get some
proper flying. And so this past year in the
north we had three or four different take offs that we had
used. So yeah, it's quite the way to
experience that part of the world.
And again, all my tours are my favourites, but that's such a
special one. Just the the interaction that
you get with the wildlife there and also the local Samburu
community, it's unparalleled. Are they are they friendly
Samburu's? Because I've I've heard some.
Yeah, extremely friendly. Yeah, extremely.
There's curious more than anything else.
I think a lot of people will get spooked and they land out in the
middle of nowhere and the Samburu warrior walk up to him
and they're holding an AK47. And that's just there to protect
their livestock, right? It's not there to harm you or
threaten you there anyways. They're just protecting their
own livestock. It's coming from from Europe,
the States. People can be thrown off guard
right away, but quick friendly smile goes a long way.
And hello. Yeah, imagine having to answer
questions with the person who's holding an AK in his hand after
your land. Holy, that's a rush in itself.
So as I said, adventure doesn't stop when the flight ends.
Thankfully Sean and our helicopter pilot Josh, they're
both fluent in Swahili, so that goes a long way too.
Definitely a lot of people speak English in Kenya too.
You'd be surprised when you find a local Sam Peru guy, full
regalia, dressed up and hello, how are you?
I I totally get what you say, man.
For anybody who's wondering how it feels like to be a celebrity
or be mobbed by people, regardless of your skill ability
or whatever you're putting out in the world, just go fly a
paraglider and land anywhere and see you become like the center
of attraction. But anyway, it's very
interesting. The cool part about this is that
we can keep on exploring our curiosities.
And but the nicer part about it is that let's leave some for the
guests so that they can figure out their own way to tickle
their own and figure out where it takes them.
But one thing I think we can promise is that usual places to
explore with a power liner, there's a bit of FOMO if you
don't hit your goal for the day right?
You're like, shit, why did I land early?
Why didn't I bomb out? But if you ever sign up for some
of these bespoke tours, I don't know the correct meaning, but I
think it's one of these exotic tours.
You will feel satisfied and end the day with a smile regardless
of your airtime. 100% couldn't agree with you more.
So anyway, if you are very keen to make the magic, then there is
a person who's already doing it and if you are keen to make the
magic in coming days, then here is another person who is going
to do it very soon. As I always say, stay tuned,
stay excited because this magic is just getting started.
Thanks so much for having me.